the Sports Illustrated columnist behind  the 2014 cover predicting the historic  Astros World Series win this week is  speaking out then writer talked to CBS  this morning about forecasting the  success of baseball's great experiment  and he gave us his prophecy for next  year it's really been quite a ride  because when the cover first came out we  got a lot of hate and that certainly  changed getting a lot of people reaching  out to me but the Powerball numbers  Dallas Keuchel one of the best pictures  on the Astro said he's gonna tweet it my  boss a request to race for me so that's  pretty nice of him I'm gonna go out on a  limb again and predict that you're 2018  champions are going to be the Astros  they're not worried about the SI jinx at  the time of riders 2014 article the  Astros had finished alas in their  division for three years in a row Ben  Rogers got to feel pretty good very good